right some breaking news coming through
Israel's prime minister says he will
seek parliamentary immunity in three
corruption cases
he's just outlined what is a rare and
contentious move and likely to delay any
potential trial against mr. Netanyahu
for months Netanyahu few recall was
indicted on charges of bribery fraud and
breach of trust in November and then he
survived a leadership test last week
after the Likud Party decided to retain
him Imran Khan and West Jerusalem for us
to take us through this so he's seeking
parliamentary immunity what does that
mean it has to be a vote there will be a
vote eventually but let me just take you
through what exactly unfolded now he had
until midnight local time tonight to ask
for this parliamentary immunity it's
been a - info Pro process with him
sometimes he said he wasn't gonna ask
for it because he'd done nothing wrong
other times he said oh the immunity is
the cornerstone of democracy he has four
hours before the deadline asked for
parliamentary immunity the process is
actually quite straightforward he just
files a letter with the Speaker of the
Knesset the Parliament and that process
then began where it gets complicated
very complicated in fact is what happens
next now Israel is going into his third
election in a year because they weren't
able to form a coalition government that
election happens at March the second so
any committee that will hear Netanyahu's
petition to be granted immunity won't be
formed until there's a government that
might take until April but and then
after that it has to be heard by the
committee the committee have to bring it
out of committee to a plenum and then it
has to be voted on by the Knesset
members he's got a political fight and
on his hands at this stage because
already people like having to Lieberman
one of the kingmakers of Israeli
politics here if he had supported
Netanyahu they wouldn't be a third
election right now there would be a
coalition government but he hasn't has
already said he's not going to support
the petition for immunity since we've
divided along party lines as well so all
of this pushes back
potential trial Netanyahu might face but
he was very clear in his speech he said
Netanyahu said immunity isn't forever
it's just for whilst he's in Parliament
so he can get on with the business of
running the country if he wins a
reelection
and that's a big if as well I mean he
hasn't won or lost elections the last
two elections though he did decisively
win the leadership Challenger in the
LaHood party he's just this he's a
political survivor isn't he he is an
absolute political survivor who's been
ruling his role for nearly a decade now
and part of his speech was very
Netanyahu was very bullish it was very
cocky was very confident he said that
the work no other leaders that it was
him that bought a prosperity to Israel
he talked about the gas pipeline that
was going to openly talk about his
achievements and it was a real
showmanship and when you do speak to
ordinary Israelis here a lot of them
will tell you that actually he's doing a
good job and they will support him
however there are a lot of people on the
Left who all center-left centrist
parties who want Netanyahu out because
they feel that he's been there for far
too long and he or she said this in his
speech he goes the only other kind of
this against me they're only qualities
are is they're not me okay thank you for
the update
Imran Khan in West Jerusalem